है गुड इवनिंग तो जो थिस इस सचिन फ्रॉम
सिक्योरिटी प्राइवेट लिमिटेड कंपनी और
अलसो डी ट्रेनर ऑफ योर
बहुत ही कम लोग ग रहे हैं लास्ट टाइम की
बहुत लोग कम तो इतनी उम्मीद नहीं थी लेकिन
उससे बहुत ज्यादा कम ठीक है हमें स्टार्ट
करना ही अपना को स्टार्ट करेंगे कंटिन्यू
जहां से हम पहले से करते आए
तो आप लोगों से रिक्वेस्ट है अगर आप लोगों
को लगता है की हमारा कंटेंट अच्छा है हम
अच्छा करवा रहे हैं यदि इस कैप्सूल कोर्स
में तो प्लीज आप लोग क्या कर दीजिए की
इसको फॉरवर्ड कीजिए मैक्सिमम लोगों को
ताकि जिनको जरूर है सच में इस कोर्स की
ठीक है जिसमें जिनको भी सच में इसको उसकी
ज्यादा जरूर है तो वह इसका बेनिफिट उठा
सकें फ्री में क्योंकि
आज का जो हमारा सेशन रहेगा वह रहेगा
रिकॉर्डिंग फाइल सिस्टम जो मैं पढ़ा चुका
हूं वो शायद सबको समझ में भी ए गया होगा
और मैं बता चुका हूं तो आज फाइल सिस्टम
हीर के बड़े में पढ़ेंगे ठीक है जो 19 या
अराउंड 19 की बात हुई थी ये मां हमारी इस
के बड़े में पढ़ने वाले हैं और दूसरा हम
अपनी कमांड्स के कमांड सीखेंगे कैसे
होती है वो कैसे क्रिएट कर सकते हैं हम
अपनी मशीन के अंदर तो अभी मैं एक बार
थोड़ा सा फैमिली
से जो विंडोज में आपका टास्कबार दिखाई
देता है ये इस तरह इसका है यहां पर आपको
क्या है लिस्ट ऑफ एप्लीकेशन देखने को
मिलती है अगर यहां पर क्लिक करते हो तो ये
सारे लिस्ट ऑफ एप्लीकेशन
है यहां पर ये आपको
डेस्कटॉप की एक इमेज दिखाई दे रहे हैं
यहां पर आपका यह दिखा रहा है आपका फाइल
फाइल सिस्टम आपको देखने को यहां पर मिल
रहा है
सिस्टम मतलब की जैसे की अब विंडो के साथ
आप कंपेयर करोगे तो दिस पीसी होता है
विंडो 11 में विंडो 10 में या इससे पहले
जब मैं के इंप्रूव होता था वो तो ये वाला
आवेश पे मैं आपको क्लिक करके दिखाऊं तो ये
आपका फाइल सिस्टम है इसमें वो सारे वो 19
या अराउंड 18th फोल्डर के बाद हुई थी वो
यही पर आपको देखने को मिलेंगे और यह क्या
ग्राफिकल गेम में आपको देखने को मिलेंगे
इसलिए मैं आपको एक बार फैमिली करवाता हूं
की जब भी आप इस मशीन को उसे करोगे तो आपको
पता चलेगी कौन सी चीज कहां पर मिलती है
उसके बाद जो आपको यहां पर दिखाई दे रहा है
ये आपका टेक्स्ट एडिटर है ठीक है बाय
डिफॉल्ट टेक्स्ट एडिटर आता है हमारी इस
मशीन के साथ ये आपको यहां देखने को मिलेगा
इसके बाद नेक्स्ट जो आपको आईकॉन दिखाई दे
रहा है ये आपको दिखाई देगा फायरफॉक्स है
ठीक है ब्राउज़र है जो आपको देखना है
सॉरी पर डिस्टरबेंस गैस आई एम सॉरी पर
क्योंकि थोड़ा सा बैकग्राउंड
है ठीक है मैं बात करेगी जी पे हम पूरा
पूरा प्रैक्टिस करने वाले हैं तो इसमें
मैं क्लिक किया अब हमारा सेलो ओपन हो गया
मेरे बस का स्क्रीन साइज बड़ा लेट हूं आप
लोगों को कम करने दिखने में अच्छा लगे
इसका साइज
अच्छे से दिखाई दे रहा होगा
ओके तो अब सबसे पहले बात करते हैं आपको
मैं बताता हूं की यह आपको दिखाई दे रहा
अगर मैं आपको एक चीज बताता हूं की इस
फाइल्स के अंदर जाते हैं तो अगर आपको न्यू
तब ओपन करना है मतलब की एक और टर्मिनल ओपन
करना तो इसमें न्यू तब करोगे तो एक और
साइड में इसका
[संगीत]
ओपन हो जाएगा जिसमें कम करने के लिए ठीक
है अगर एक साथ मल्टीपल को अपने उसे करना
है एक टर्मिनल में आपका कोई टास्क और
टास्क का कम चल रहा है तो अगर आपको दूसरे
टर्मिनल को उसे करना है तो इसी में
क्या-क्या है न्यू टाइप पे जाओगे तो आप
दूसरे टर्मिनल को उसे कर पाओगे अगर अदर
वाइस आप क्या कर सकते हो अगर आपको क्या
करना है आपको ये आपको ऐसे नहीं करना आपको
क्या है ये सिंपली इसको स्प्लिट भी कर
सकते हो अगर मैं स्प्लिट वर्जन प्ले किया
तो ये कैमरा ओरिजनली स्प्लिट हो जाएगा दो
भाग में आपके स्क्रीन डिवाइड हो जाएगी
एडरवाइज आप वर्टिकली भी इसको स्प्लिट कर
सकते हैं ऐसे क्लिक करके नेक्स्ट बात करते
हैं अब हम
इसी के बड़े में जो आपको स्क्रीन पर शो हो
रहा है ठीक है की ये क्या चीज है जो मैं
आपको हाईलाइट कर रहा हूं ये चीज है क्या
देखो सबसे पहले जो आपको दिखाई दे रहा होगा
ये है रूट ये है रूट
ये सबसे पहले आपको दिखाई दे रहा है वो ये
है रूट
मतलब यूजर नाम
यह क्या है आपका यूजर नाम आता है इस मशीन
का जो अभी यूजर्स नाम है वो है रोड ठीक है
इसके बाद की जो लास्ट में दिखाई दे रहा है
ये आपका होस्ट नाम शो करता है मशीन का जो
होस्ट नाम होता है उसको शो करता है उसके
बाद जो आपको ये दिखाई दे रहा है ब्रैकेट
में जो ये तिल्ली साइन दिखाई दे रहा है
बेसिकली यहां पर अभी इसका मतलब है तिलतेड
साइन का होम डायरेक्टरी मतलब जो यूजर्स है
रूट यूजर्स है ठीक है इसकी ये होम
डायरेक्टर देखो शो कर रहा है
अब ठीक है उसके बाद क्या करते हैं उसके
बाद जो आपको दिखाई दे रहा है ये आईकॉन ठीक
है ये हेज दिखाई दे रहा है यहां पर आपको
दो आईकॉन देखने को मिलेंगे ठीक है या तो
देखने को मिलेगा या आपको देखने को मिलेगा
जैसे न्यू करता हूं तो यहां पे देखो अगर
हम इसका साइज बड़ा के दिखाऊं आपको ये रहा
अगर आपको ये दिखाई दे रहा है डॉलर तब मतलब
क्या है की आपने एक नॉर्मल यूजर अकाउंट से
लॉगिन किया हुआ है इस मशीन के अंदर और
यहां पर देखो ये वो यूजर का नाम है काली
ठीक है ये इसकी यूजर का नाम है और यहां पर
ये आपको दिखाई दे रहा है तिल डेट चाहिए
इसकी होम डायरेक्टली बेसिकली यहां पर साइन
नहीं होता है यहां पर बेसिकली होता है की
प्रेजेंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टली मतलब की
प्रेजेंटली आप किस डायरेक्टली के अंदर कम
कर रहे हैं यहां पर वो आएगी ये तिलतेड
साइन है इसका मतलब क्या है की अभी आप इस
यूजर की होम डायरेक्टर के अंदर है अगर आप
इधर के किसी भी दूसरी डायरेक्टर के अंदर
शिफ्ट करोगे तो यहां पर डायरेक्टली का नाम
ए जाएगा बेसिकली तो यहां पर जो इनफॉरमेशन
सो होती है आपको ये है आपकी प्रेजेंट
वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी की इनफॉरमेशन ठीक है
अब मैं बात करते हैं फाइव सिस्टम हीरे की
जिसमें मैं बात करने वाला हूं अभी क्या है
की पुरी की पुरी फाइल सिस्टम ए रहा है की
आपको पता है
अच्छे से दिखाई दे
सबसे पहले
लास्ट क्लास में बताया था सबसे पहले आता
है ठीक है अराउंड
अराउंड हो शक्ति है कुछ भी हो सकता है ठीक
है और इसके अंदर सब डायरेक्ट होती है
फाइल्स होती है ये सबको पता है बट बट इससे
पहले कुछ भी नहीं है ठीक है स्टार्टिंग
होती है इसी के नीचे डिफाइन डाटा होता है
और इसी के नीचे आपका आ डिफाइन डाटा होता
है पूरा पूरा स्ट्रक्चर यही से स्टार्ट
होता है अब हम पढ़ने वाले हैं इस
स्ट्रक्चर को ठीक है इसके अंदर जो अराउंड
19 है 17 15 जो भी होगी हमारी मशीन में
उसके बड़े में पता करने वाले हैं कौन-कौन
सी हैं तो सबसे पहले मैं क्या करता हूं
शिफ्ट करता हूं एक बार मैं अभी 1 मिनट का
मतलब क्या है
आपको स्क्रीन पर दिखाई दे रहा होगा ठीक है
ये वो कौन-कौन सी एंटी डायरेक्टली क्योंकि
ये सबसे पहले यही है वो रूट पार्टीशन ठीक
है रूट पार्टीशन के अंदर मैंने क्या बताया
था इसके नीचे कितनी होगी अराउंड 19 या
17th जो भी डायरेक्टर हूं
ये वो अराउंड वाली डायरेक्ट
45678910
क्या मतलब होता है थोड़ा सा आपको आइडिया
मिल जाएगा की हर एक डायरेक्टर में इजरायल
का डाटा आपको देखने को मिलता है प्रोडक्ट
की जब भी आप कम करोगे तो आपको आइडिया
रहेगा एक चीज ध्यान रखना बहुत लोगों को
क्या लगता है की लास्ट क्लास में जब मैंने
पटाया था तो बहुत लोगों को डाउट ही राहत
है की मैं इसमें क्यों कम करूं ठीक है इस
डायरेक्टरी में मैं भी तो क्या कर सकता
हूं अपने फाइल बना सकता हूं इसमें कम भी
कर सकता हूं ठीक है तो मुझे अब इनकी जरूर
क्या है देखो क्या है की लाइनेक्स में
पहले से डिफाइन कर दिया गया है किसी पर
किसी फाइल को जैसे की प्रोग्राम पहले तो
प्रोग्राम फाइल को जहां पर डिपेंड होता है
डाउनलोड होना है वो वहीं पर जाएगी ठीक है
उसके बाद जहां पर इंस्टॉल होगा उसको
एग्जीक्यूट होना वो वहीं पर होगी बाय
डिफॉल्ट क्या है की वो इनकी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
फाइल में मेंशन है मतलब क्या है
कम के परपज से उसे परमिशन डिफाइन करते
करते हुए पॉलिसी डिपेंड करते हुए हर एक
डायरेक्टरी को पहले से डिफाइन कर दिया गया
है अब उसके हिसाब से कम करोगे तो
कंफर्टेबल टी र गया एडरवाइज क्या है की
उसे डायरेक्टरी का कम और किसी डायरेक्टरी
के अंदर करोगे तो आपको प्रॉब्लम फेस
मिलेगी किसकी परमीशंस की इसलिए एडरवाइज
करने को तो आप चाहे भूत के अंदर कम करो या
आप मीडिया के अंदर कम करो एमएमटी के अंदर
करो या किसी भी डायरेक्टर के अंदर कम करो
वो फर्क नहीं पड़ेगा फर्क पड़ता है
परमीशंस का मतलब लोगों के दिमाग में पहले
सवाल यही आता है की मैं तो उधर भी फाइल
बना लेट हूं तो मेरा तो कम चल रहा है तो
बाकी फिर ये फाइल एक ही है देखो इनका अपना
अपना परपज से बनाया गया था इस परपज में
आपको उसे इस परपज के हिसाब से इनको उसे
करना चाहिए अब बहुत लोगों को एक और नया
कन्फ्यूजन राहत है की नया कन्फ्यूजन क्या
राहत है की जब भी हम क्या करते हैं
की एक रूट पार्टीशन की बात करते हैं ठीक
है रूट पार्टीशन में एक तो ये फॉरवर्ड
लाइसेंस जो आपको दिखाई दे रहा होगा
स्क्रीन पर दूसरा क्या है एक और आपको मैं
दिखाऊं एक और ये ऐसे उसे करते हैं रूट
इसको भी हम कई बार क्या है रूट बोल देते
हैं ठीक है अब दोनों को रोटी बोलते हैं
ये क्या है आपका रूट पार्टीशन है मतलब
सबसे टॉप लेवल ए रहा है हर लड़की में सबसे
टॉप इससे ऊपर कोई नहीं है इससे भी और कुछ
नहीं है सर कम इसके नीचे होता है अब जो ये
रूट आपको दिखाई दे रहा है ये होता है आपका
जो रूट यूजर है जो सुपर यूजर है यह उसका
क्या है होम अकाउंट है उसके होम अकाउंट की
इनफॉरमेशन मतलब की है उसका जो प्राइवेट
अकाउंट है जिसकी मैंने प्राइवेट पब्लिक
प्लेस की बात हुई थी ना तो ये वाला उसका
प्राइवेट फॉर्म अकाउंट की यहां पर बात
करती है जो 19 में से दो डायरेक्टली होती
है एक तो सुपर यूजर्स की होम अकाउंट के
लिए रहती है और एक आपकी जो रहती है नॉर्मल
यूजर्स की होम अकाउंट के लिए रहती है तो
यहां पर ये जो रूट यूजर्स है उसकी होम
अकाउंट के बाद होती है तो यही डिफरेंस
इनमें क्योंकि अब कुछ लोग समझ सकते हैं और
इसी में जब कम करेंगे बोला आपने तो ऐसा
बताया था आप ऐसा बताया नहीं क्योंकि इनमें
यही डिफरेंस है ये एक रूट पार्टीशन है ये
क्या है रूट की होम डायरेक्टरी है चलो अब
स्टार्ट करता हूं सबसे पहले
ठीक है अब सबसे पहले जो आपकी डायरेक्टरी
आई है वो आई है
क्या होता है
इसके अंदर आपको क्या करता है की जितने भी
फाइल्स होती हैं जितनी भी फाइल होती है
आपकी मशीन के अंदर ठीक है वह आपको इसके
अंदर देखने को मिलेगी अब बाइनरी फाइल्स
क्या होती है देखो किसी भी कमांड को ठीक
है जितने भी कमांड आप अपनी लाइनेक्स मशीन
में उसे करते हो उसको चलने के लिए उसको रन
करने के लिए प्रोग्राम्स की जरूर होती है
ठीक है और प्रोग्राम्स क्या होते हैं
सेट्स ऑफ इंस्ट्रक्शंस होते हैं
इंस्ट्रक्शन होते हैं तो बाद में जब उसको
मशीन में एग्जीक्यूट करना होता है मशीन
में चलना होता है उसको क्या है की एक
फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट कर दिया जाता है जीरो
वन के फॉर्म में जिनको हम बोलते हैं
बाइनरी फॉर्म ठीक है तो हर एक हर एक कमांड
की एक प्रोग्राम फाइल होती है और जो
बाइनरी फॉर्म होती है और जो जिनको हम
एग्जीक्यूटिव फाइल्स बोलते हैं तो उन सभी
फाइल्स की चाय कोई भी कमांड वाली
फाइल्स आपको यहां पर देखने को मिलेगी अगर
मैं इस बार इसके अंदर जाता हूं
अगर मैं आपको लिस्ट करके दिखा ता हूं ये
रहा ये जितने भी हैं ये साड़ी की साड़ी
आपको दिखाई देगी ये साड़ी की साड़ी बाइनरी
फाइल्स है कोई ना कोई कोई ना कोई कमांड की
है कोई ना कोई प्रोग्राम भी फाइल्स आपको
देखने को मिलेंगे
अब चलते हैं नेक्स्ट डायरेक्टरी के अंदर
ठीक है
और यहां पर सबसे जो इंपॉर्टेंट डायरेक्टरी
इसके अंदर ये ग्राम है ठीक है इसके अंदर
क्या होता है इसके अंदर आपका बुटलोडर
प्रोग्राम होता है
प्रोग्राम क्या होता है देखो जब भी आपका
मशीन भूत करती है ठीक है जब भी आपकी मशीन
बोट करते हैं तो उसको क्या करता है उसको
एक सीक्वेंस में भूत करना होता है ठीक है
उसे बहुत सारे कंफीग्रेशन फाइल्स की जरूर
होती है ठीक है पार्टीशन से उसको
हार्डवेयर हार्डवेयर के मॉडल की जरूर होती
है करनाल की जरूर होती है और सबको आपस में
ऑन होने के लिए बहुत साड़ी चीजों की जरूर
होती है तो यहां पर क्या है
ठीक है
जो एक सीक्वेंस में कम करता है इसके नीचे
आपको एक चीज और दिखाई देगी यहां पर ये रहा
यहां पर कंफीग्रेशन फाइल ठीक है
कमेंट में बता दीजिएगा प्लीज
इट्स कंफर्टेबल
ओके ओके चलो अब बात करते हम कंटिन्यू करते
हैं तो अब मैं बता रहा था यह ठीक है जो
आपको यहां पर दिखाई दे रही है कॉन्फ़िग
6.1.0 काली i7 i90 ठीक है डिपेंड करती है
जैसे आपने अपनी मशीन को अपडेट किया हुआ है
तो इसके अंदर क्या मिलता है देखो आपका जब
अपने सिस्टम फर्स्ट टाइम ब्रेकअप होता है
ठीक है तो फर्स्ट टाइम वाले अप होते हैं
वक्त मतलब जबकि फर्स्ट टाइम चला था कुछ
उसके उसको क्या है कौन सा सीक्वेंस फूल
होता है और वो सीक्वेंस क्या करता है अदर
कॉम्पोनेंट्स को क्या करता है वाले अप
करता है दूसरे कंपोनेंट क्या करता स्टार्ट
करता है अब मेरा खाने का मतलब क्या होता
है की जब भी आपने पावर ऑन बटन किया प्रेस
किया आपने मशीन का पावर बटन प्रेस करते
हैं क्या होता है की आपकी मशीन मैं करंट
फ्लो होता है और सबसे पहले क्या है आपका
स्टार्ट हो जाता है मशीन वोटिंग करना
स्टार्ट कर दिया उसे भूत अप को क्या कहा
एक सीक्वेंस में किया जाता है ठीक है सबसे
पहले पोस्ट चेक होता है बोसोम होता है ठीक
है उसके बाद क्या है की करनाल लोड होता है
करनाल के साथ हार्डवेयर के मॉडल लोड होते
हैं ठीक है जो मॉडल को बेसिकली ड्राइवर
सकते हैं ठीक है उसे और उनसे पहले सबसे
पहले चेकिंग होती है सारे जो कॉम्पोनेंट्स
हैं आपके हार्डवेयर कंपोनेंट है वो सही है
या नहीं है वो साड़ी की साड़ी चीज जो होती
हैं जब भी आपने अगर आपकी मशीन को ऑन किया
होगा आपने इसलिए नेट की मशीन को तो एक
ब्लैक स्प्रिंग पे बहुत साड़ी लाइन चलती
है ठीक है वो सर एक सीक्वेंस में कम होता
है ठीक है जिसको हम बोलते हैं बीटिंग
सीक्वेंस तो उनसे रिलेटेड जो भी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन है वो उसमें मतलब की
सीक्वेंस में कौन सा कम होना चाहिए वो
यहां कंफीग्रेशन फाइल्स में डिफाइन राहत
है और गर्भ में बहुत लोडर प्रोग्राम होता
है ठीक है भूत कैसे होगी मशीन वो
प्रोग्राम से क्या होता है क्योंकि
कंफीग्रेशन फाइल में डिपेंड डिफाइंड होगा
की ग्रुप जो ग्रुप आ भूत लोडर प्रोग्राम्स
अगर अब के अंदर ठीक है उसको कैसे
एग्जीक्यूट करना है वो इसी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
फाइल में डिफाइंड होगा स्टेप बाय स्टेप
में जाके अगर आप इसको कैट करके देखोगे तो
आपको मैं पता चल जाएगा
वो है आपकी नेक्स्ट डायरेक्टरी ए गई हमारी
पी हो गया भूत हो गया अब ए जाति है ठीक है
डायरेक्टली के बड़े में क्या होता है इसको
बोलते हैं डिवाइस फाइल्स
में एक डायरेक्ट
फाइल में अब क्या होता है की ये एक स्पेशल
टाइप की फाइल होती है
जब भी हमारा हार्डवेयर जो भी हमारा
हार्डवेयर होता है वह सॉफ्टवेयर होता है
उनके बीच में जो इंटरफेस का कम करती है ना
वो होती है आपकी डिवाइस फाइल ठीक है वो
होती है आपकी देवता ठीक है डिवाइस फाइल वो
इनके बीच में इसका कम करती है देखो क्या
होता है की हार्डवेयर में हमारा डाटा दो
दो तरह से ट्रांसमिट होता है ठीक है हमारे
डाटा भी जो ट्रांसमिट होता है दो तरह से
ट्रांसफर हो गए तो डाटा ब्लॉक की फॉर्म
में एक करैक्टर की फॉर्म में जो ब्लॉक की
फॉर्म में डाटा होता है वो क्या चेस में
चेस में डिवाइड हो जाता है और चेस में वो
क्या करता है फ्लो होता है ठीक है बेसिकली
जब हार्डवेयर के अंदर जो डाटा फ्लो होता
है वो क्या होता है आपका ब्लॉक के फॉर्म
में जाता है अब करैक्टर की फॉर्म में कौन
सा डाटा जाता है बेसिकली ये पर एग्जांपल
लेट हूं माइक को स्पीकर के बीच में जो
डाटा फ्लो होता है उसको हम बोल सकते हैं
की वो डाटा फ्लो कर रहा है करैक्टर की
फॉर्म में मतलब की इस डायरेक्टर के अंदर
जितनी भी डिवाइसेज हैं जो भी डिवाइसेज
फाइल्स है ठीक है हार्डवेयर से रिलेटेड
उनके इंटरफेस रिलेटेड वो आपको देखने को
मिलेगी एक चीज ध्यान रखना मेरे दोस्तों की
लिरिक्स में हर एक चीज फाइल है
हार्ड डिस्क लगाओ पेन ड्राइव लगाओ कुछ भी
लाइनेक्स हर चीज को
इसके अंदर जाके देखा था फाइल के अंदर
डायरेक्ट करता हूं यहां पर क्या है बहुत
साड़ी आपको ब्लॉक फाइल देखने को मिलेंगे
अगर मैं ये करता हूं
आंखों को पता चला है देखो सी करैक्टर फाइल
है यह
डायरेक्टरी है उसके अलावा देखो
यहां पर दिखाई दे रहा होगा
आने वाले टाइम में तो बेसिकली देखो
आईडेंटिफाई करें सीडी दे मतलब डायरेक्ट
मतलब करैक्टर फाइल बी मतलब ब्लॉक फाइल एस
मतलब सॉकेट फाइल ठीक है अब यहां पर साड़ी
ब्लॉक फाइल्स की इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को
मिलती है
नेक्स्ट चलते हैं अब हम
नेक्स्ट हमारा ए गया 8c ठीक है
वो इसके अंदर आपको देखने को मिलती है
सिस्टम की जो सेटिंग्स होती हैं
कुछ भी होता है वो आपको यहां पर देखने को
मिलती है
मतलब क्या है इसका देखो होम डायरेक्टर के
अंदर आपको देखने को मिल रहा है
नॉर्मल यूजर्स होते ना आपके रूट के अलावा
और सभी के सभी इस होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर
आपको देखने को मिलते हैं अगर हम इस
डायरेक्टर के अंदर आपको जा के दिखता हूं
तो ये रहा और मैंने इस देखो इसके अंदर अभी
मेरे पास क्या है एक यूजर मशीन के लिए
बनाया हुआ है जिसका नाम काली है इसलिए एक
ही दिन आपको देखने को मिल रहा है एडरवाइज
अगर आपने दो कर पांच जितने भी यूजर बनाए
होते हैं वो सारे के सारे इसी होम
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर देखने को मिलते हैं
यही वही होम डायरेक्टरी है जो हमने बोला
था ये प्राइवेट प्लेस ऑफ ए नॉर्मल यूजर
जितने भी जो नॉर्मल यूजर्स होते हैं उनका
प्राइवेट प्लेस नहीं है ठीक है अब बात
करता हूं नेक्स्ट ए गया हमारा अब ये देखो
ये जो चीज हैं
क्या चीज है ये क्या है जो फाइल्स है आपकी
भूत वाली जो फाइल्स है ना ये भूत वाली
डायरेक्ट भी है इसी के अंदर से ली गई है
मैं दिखाऊंगा कैसे आपको आईडेंटिफाई होगा
क्योंकि ये इस के अंदर से ले गई लेकिन
स्क्रीन पर लेकर आएगी ये सामने ये
लाइब्रेरी भी क्या है अब ल आई बी ठीक है
ये क्या है
यहां पर क्या है की आपको लाइब्रेरी फाइल्स
की इनफॉरमेशन देखने मिलती है इस डायरेक्टर
के अंदर देखो किसी भी एप्लीकेशन को क्या
होता है रन होने के लिए नहीं लाइब्रेरी की
जरूर होती है ठीक है और वो इनफॉरमेशन आपको
इसके अंदर देखने को मिलेगी अगर मैं इसके
अंदर जाके दिखाऊं आपको
अगर मैं करता हूं देखो
मिलेगा यह साड़ी के सारे क्या किसी ने
किसी प्रोग्राम जैसे हैं हमारे जो वेब
सर्वर होता है उसकी जो लाइब्रेरी फाइल्स
होगी ठीक है उसके एक डायरेक्टरी बन रही है
इसके अंदर उसके लिए जो लाइब्रेरी फाइल्स
की जरूर है रिटायरमेंट है इसको बैंड करने
के लिए वो इसके अंदर स्टोर है मतलब
बेसिकली मैंने कहा की एप्लीकेशन रन करने
के लिए जिन लाइब्रेरी फाइल्स की
रिटायरमेंट होती है वो यहां पर आपको देखने
को मिलेगी
अब बात करते हैं यहां पर ए गया
है ठीक है
यहां पे बात हो रही है अब बात करते हैं
इंपॉर्टेंट फाइल लास्ट प्लस में फाइंड ठीक
है लास्ट प्लस में फाइन जो डायरेक्टली
इसके बड़े में बात करते हैं अब क्या होता
है की जब भी कोई भी एक पर्टिकुलर
प्रोग्राम क्या होता है की करप्ट कर जाए
या आप क्या कर रहे हो की आपका आप अपने
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम पे कम कर रहे हैं और
सुद्दनली वो क्या हो गया वो टर्न ऑफ हो
गया
आपके लैपटॉप में बैटरी नहीं रही सुद्दनली
वो क्या हो गया वो टर्न ऑफ हो गया अब क्या
ए गया उसमें बहुत सारे प्रोग्राम्स रन कर
रहे होंगे ठीक है अब प्रोग्राम रनिंग
कंडीशन
हो जाते हैं ठीक है ऑटोमेटेकली वो रिकॉर्ड
हो जाते हैं अब कुछ प्रोग्राम्स ऐसे भी
होंगे जो सही तरह से रिकवर नहीं हो पे
होंगे ठीक है तो वो आपको यहां पर देखने को
मिल सकते हैं
एक चीज बता देता हूं आपको इंपॉर्टेंट
इनफॉरमेशन है
क्या होता है की देखो क्या होता है जब
सिस्टम स्क्रैच होता है तो किसी ने किसी
पर्टिकुलर प्रोसेस के करण ही क्रश हुआ
होगा ठीक है अब क्या होता है की
जब डिजिटल फैंसी किया जाएगा अब यह पता
किया जाएगा की यह पर्टिकुलर प्रोसेस किसकी
वजह से क्रश हुई होगी किस प्रोग्राम की
वजह से प्रेस हो गई है किसकी वजह किस
फाइल्स की वजह से हुई होगी ठीक है तो हो
सकता है की वो इनफॉरमेशन आके लॉस प्लस
फाइंड के अंदर आके आपको देखने को मिल जाए
ठीक है हो सकता है पूरा रिकवर कर गई होगी
क्रश होने के बाद भी तो यहां पर नहीं भी
मिले लेकिन चांसेस होते हैं डिजिटल पवन
सिंह के टाइम में अगर यह पता करने के की
कोई पर्टिकुलर प्रोसेस अगर खराब हुई है
क्रश हुई है तो वो किस प्रोसेस या फाइल की
वजह से हुई होगी वो जनरली वो इंश्योरेंस
है आपको इसके अंदर देखने को मिल जाति है
लास्ट प्लस फॉर्म डायरेक्टली के अंदर
डिजिटल फोंसिक वालों के लिए ये इंपॉर्टेंट
डायरेक्टरी कई बार बन जाति है अब बात करते
हैं मीडिया डायरेक्टली ठीक है ये मीडिया
डायरेक्टर के बड़े में बता इसमें क्या है
बेसिकली सीधी सी बात है मीडिया फाइल की
बात हो रही है मतलब जितनी भी रिमूवल
मीडिया होती है सीडी ड्राइव यस ठीक है
मीडिया वाली बातें हो रही है तो वो इसके
अंदर देखने को मिलेगी ठीक है जब भी आप
बूंद करेंगे
ठीक है
अगर आपकी सिस्टम में सीडी ड्राइव होगी
आजकल किसी सिस्टम में है नहीं अगर आपके
सिस्टम में सीडी ड्राइव होगी तो क्या होगा
या तो वह ऑटोमेटेकली यहां अमाउंट वही
मिलेगी या ऑटोमेटेकली यहां अमाउंट
का क्या मतलब है मैं बताऊंगा अभी ठीक है
तो ये है रिमूव मीडिया से रिलेटेड जो
फाइल्स है जो इनफॉरमेशन आपको इनडायरेक्ट
के अंदर देखने को मिलती है अब मैं बात
करता एमएमटी डायरेक्टरी ठीक है एमएमटी
मतलब माउंटेन ठीक है अब ये नॉर्मली आपको
एमपी मिलेगी ठीक है जब भी हम क्या करते
हैं कोई भी आइसो इमेज को उसे करते हैं
आईओएस इमेज को कब उसे करते हैं हो सकता है
की आपने अब लोकल रिपोजिटरी कॉन्फ़िगर करनी
है हो सकता है की आपका प्रोग्राम करप्ट हो
गया हूं ठीक है आपका करना करेक्ट हो गया
हो उसको रिकवर करना हो तो हम क्या करते
हैं की जो आपकी आइसो इमेज है उसको हम क्या
करते हैं माउंट करते हैं ठीक है या किसी
पेन ड्राइव को हमने क्या किया इंसर्ट किया
हार्ड डिस्क को इंसर्ट किया
तो वह क्या उसको जब हम माउंट करते हैं ना
तो उसकी जो एंट्री है जो बंटी है जो माउंट
होती है वह इस डायरेक्टर के अंदर माउंट
होती है अब माउंट का मतलब क्या होता है
ठीक है माउंट का मतलब होता है की अगर हमें
किसी भी डिवाइस से डाटा का लेन-देन करना
है ठीक है पेन ड्राइव से या हार्ड डिस्क
से तो उसको माउंट करना जरूरी है दम तक हम
उसको माउंट नहीं करेंगे तब तक उसके अंदर
डाटा फ्लो नहीं हो सकता माउंटिंग का मतलब
ये होता है बेसिकली क्या है की माउंट का
मतलब ये होता है की जैसे की आपका घर है
ठीक है एक कैमरा है अगर उसमें खिड़की कोई
दरवाजा ही नहीं लगाया तो उसके अंदर आदमी
कैसे आजाद करेंगे उसको कैसे उसे कर पाएंगे
तो बेसिकली माउंट का मतलब वही होता है की
एक कैमरा है अगर उसको मेरे को उसे करना है
उसके अंदर एक दरवाजा लगा हुआ है ठीक है
उसे दरवाजे के लिए आपका आना जाना राहत है
तो इसी तरह इसमें होता है माउंट जब तक आप
किसी भी एक रोल मीडिया को या किसी भी
हार्ड डिस्क को या ऐसे मेरे को जब तक
माउंट नहीं करोगे तब तक आप इसको उसे नहीं
अब मैं बात करता हूं ऑप्ट की ऑप्शनल
सॉफ्टवेयर
दिया गया है आप चाहे तो क्या कर सकते हो
की जो आपके थर्ड पार्टी सॉफ्टवेयर्स हैं
उनको यहां पर क्या कर सकते हो इंस्टॉल कर
सकते हो उसे कर सकते हो ठीक है इसका मतलब
था ऑप्शन सॉफ्टवेयर
अब क्या होता है की जो यह प्रोग्राम
डायरेक्टर है ना यह डायरेक्टली करनाल से
अपडेट होती है इसमें बिल्कुल कुछ भी चेंज
होता प्रोसेस में कोई भी प्रोसेस अपलोड
हुई है प्रोसेस कम कर रही है जितनी भी
प्रोसेस रिलेटेड
वो डायरेक्टली क्या होती है
और कई बार हम जब क्या होता है की बाकी जो
कमांड्स कम करती है कई बार हम प्रोसेस से
रिलेटेड इनफॉरमेशन देखते हैं टॉप कमांड का
उसे करते हैं हम प्रोसेस की इनफॉरमेशन
देखते हैं स्टेट देखते हैं तो वो कहां से
देखते हैं वो इसी के थ्रू वो क्या करते
हैं बैकग्राउंड में इसका डिफरेंस लेते और
उसके बाद आपसे आउटपुट में शो करती हैं
अब बात करते हैं रूट इसके मैं बात कर रहा
था ये क्या है जो रूट सुपर यूजर है उसका
होम अकाउंट है ठीक है उसके होम अकाउंट की
डायरेक्टरी है अगर मैं इसके अंदर जाके
आपको दिखता हूं तो ये टेंडर करता हूं तो
ये है ये सुपर यूजर्स का उसका डेस्कटॉप
उसका डॉक्यूमेंट उसका डाउनलोड उसका
म्यूजिक ऐसा ही उसको जो नॉर्मल यूजर्स का
जो होम अकाउंट था उसके अंदर जो कल नाम का
जो यूजर्स बना हुआ था उसके अंदर भी अगर आप
चेंज करके देखोगे उसके अंदर की इनफॉरमेशन
भी ऐसे ही आपको देखने को मिलेगी ठीक है तो
ये उसका क्या है जो प्राइवेट प्लेस है
उसके अंदर की इनफॉरमेशन
वापस जाता हूं अब बात करते हैं
[संगीत]
मतलब क्या है इसके अंदर भी बैटरी फाइल्स
आपको देखने को मिलेंगे लेकिन कौन सी बैटरी
फाइल्स आपको देखने को मिलेगी इसमें सुपर
यूजर्स की बहन जी मतलब स्टंप्स में मशीन
में जो लाइनेक्स मशीन है कुछ ऐसी कमांड्स
होती हैं जिनको सिर्फ सुपर यूजर ही रन कर
सकता है सुपर यूजर ही चला सकता है और तो
उनकी जो बेनिफिट्स है वो साड़ी की साड़ी
क्या है इस एसबीआईइन डायरेक्टरी के अंदर
आपको देखने को मिलती है ठीक है अब एस आर
बी डायरेक्ट के बड़े में बात करते हैं
आपको देखने को मिल रही है
सर्विंग डायरेक्टरी मतलब क्या है
एफटीपी एनएफसी या कोई भी एक प्रोक्सी
सर्वर कॉन्फ़िगर कर दिया ठीक है अब कई बार
क्या होता है की हमें जो हमारी यूजर्स
होते हैं उनको अपना टेंपरेरी डाटा क्या
करना है हॉल करके रखना होता है जब भी उसे
सर्विस को मैं उसे करूं तो मैं जल्दी से
उसे डाटा को एक्सेस करता हूं मतलब लाइक ए
कैची जब आप सिस्टम में कैसे मेमोरी क्यों
उसे करते हैं ताकि आपकी स्पीड प्रोसेसिंग
पावर बाढ़ जाए वही इसी तरीके से बोल सकते
हो की जब भी आपको भी जब ये सर्विसेज उसे
करते हो कोई प्रोक्सी सर्वर कॉन्फ़िगर
करके सर्वर कन्फ्यूजन है कुछ भी कॉन्फ़िगर
किया लाइक डेट और एफ सर्वर तो वहां पर
क्या है की कुछ टेंपरेरी फाइल होती है जो
आप यूजर्स के लिए क्या है इसमें इसके अंदर
क्या है से करके रखते हो जैसे ही जब वो
सर्विस आप उसे करोगे तो
फास्टली रेस्पॉन्ड मिले हम एक्सेस कर पे
उन फाइल्स को ठीक है उसे डाटा को बेसिकली
ये मतलब होता है इसका ये इसलिए इसका नाम
मैं लिखा एक सर्विंग डायरेक्टरी अब बात
करते हैं जो आपकी
बात करते हैं
इसके अंदर क्या होता है
इसके अंदर आपको क्या देखने को मिलता है
ठीक है करनाल से रिलेटेड और हार्डवेयर से
रिलेटेड जितनी भी डीटेल्स हैं इसके अंदर
देखने को मिलती है ठीक है कर्नल्स के
रिलेटेड जो हार्डवेयर रिलेटेड है जो उनके
वागब में इसके अंदर आपको जा के दिखता हूं
तो ये इंटर ल एस किया अब देखो इसमें क्या
है करनाल और हार्डवेयर सिलेक्ट काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट है ब्लॉक ब्लॉक डिवाइसेज की
इनफॉरमेशन है बस की जो डाटा केवल लाने ले
जान के लिए कम करती हैं क्लास डिवाइस ठीक
है फ्रॉम वेयर ठीक है
करनाल मॉडल जो ड्राइवर है मतलब क्या है की
जो हार्डवेयर हैं या करनाल पार्ट है उनके
मॉडलिंग से रिलेटेड जो इनफॉरमेशन है इसके
अंदर आपको देखने को मिलती है
आप लोगों को बेसिकली आपको पता होना चाहिए
की हां मेरी कन्फ्यूजन फाइल कहां पर
मिलेगी मेरी हां बाइनरी फाइल कहां पर
मिलेगी हां मुझे कम कहां करना है ठीक है
ऑप्टिकल में क्या मिलेगा ठीक है प्रोक में
अच्छा हां और लाइव अपडेट होती है करनाल से
हमें क्या बेसिक आपको एक बेसिक आइडिया
होना चाहिए लेकिन जैसे-जैसे आप यूजर
फ्रेंडली हो जाओगे उसके साथ जैसे-जैसे आप
इन्हें इसको उसे करना शुरू कर डॉग तो और
ऑटोमेटेकली की है ना ये इनके बड़े में
अपने आप ही आपको पता चल जाएगी अच्छा इसका
मतलब ये है मुझे यहां कम करना है क्योंकि
एक दिन में कितना होता लूं आप कितना दीप
में जाऊं आपको समझ में नहीं आएगा क्योंकि
बहुत सारे ऐसे बिगनर्स लोग होंगे जिनको
पूरा ही आइडिया नहीं होंगे चीज क्या है तो
इसलिए क्या है की बस उनके बड़े में पता
होना चाहिए की हां ये चीज है आप मैं कम कर
रहा हूं लिरिक्स में ये इतने फोल्डर हैं
इतनी डायरेक्टर्स हैं इनका मतलब ये है
बेसिकली कुछ भी कम करोगे उससे रिलेटेड अगर
कहानी नाम भी सनोज इस रिलेटेड कोई कम हो
रहा होगा ना आपको सीधा दिमाग में आएगा
अच्छा हां मुझे फोल्डर में जाके या उसे
लाइक तुम जाके चेक करना चाहिए हो सकता है
या वहां मिलेगा तो आपको पक्का नहीं मानना
पड़ेगा किसी चीज को ढूंढने के लिए घंटे
नहीं लगाना पड़ेगा आपको सिर्फ जस्ट 1 मिनट
की मेमोरी के साथ आप कम कर डॉग अब बात
करते हैं इसकी टीएनपी डायरेक्टर की ये
होती है आपकी टीएनपी डायरेक्टरी मतलब यहां
पर ये एक टेंपरेरी डायरेक्टरी होती है ठीक
है इसको हर कोई एक्सेस कर सकता है
डिलीट कर सकता है लेकिन इसमें क्या होता
है ना की इसमें जी यूजर ने जी फाइल को
क्रिएट किया है तो वही यूजर इसी फाइल को
डिलीट कर सकता है उसे यूजर की फाइल को कोई
भी डिलीट नहीं कर सकता रूट की बात नहीं कर
रहा नॉर्मल की बात कर रहा हूं ठीक है मतलब
ये काली नाम का जो यूजर है इस मशीन का अगर
काली नाम की यूजर्स ने टीएनपी डायरेक्टरी
के अंदर कोई अपना कम किया है ठीक है अपनी
फाइल क्रिएट की है तो कल को आया जैसे मेरा
नाम सचिन है मैंने मैं यूजर्स हूं मैंने
ओपन किया क्योंकि सबको एसेसरीज
को सबको
डिलीट कर दिया ऐसा नहीं हो सकता क्योंकि
यहां पर एक स्टिकी बीट लगी होती है
जिसकी वजह से क्या होता है की
वो फाइल है जी वीडियो ने उसको क्रिएट किया
है वही उसको डिलीट कर सकता है कोई दूसरा
डिलीट नहीं कर सकता ऐसा कम करते हैं
बेसिकली एक ऐसी जगह है यहां पर क्या कोई
भी अपना कम कर सकता है यहां पर साड़ी
परमेश्वर होती है टेंपरेरी है ठीक है ये
जैसे ये फाइल्स आपकी डिलीट हो जाति है
टेंपरेरी कम करने के लिए बेसिकली अब मैं
बात कर रहा हूं
अब इसके अंदर भी आपको
बेनिफिट देखने को मिलेगी ठीक है लाइवली
फाइल भी देखने को मिलेगी और डॉक्यूमेंट से
रिलेटेड आपको देखने को मिलेगी इस यू एस आर
डायरेक्टर के अंदर अब आपको लास्ट में पूरा
एक बार साइड का इंट्रो दे देता हूं उसके
बाद बताता हूं की
फोन कैसे रिलेटेड है अब उसके बाद बताता
हूं वार अब मैं बात करता हूं वह एक
वेरिएबल फाइल ठीक है
ये डायरेक्टर के अंदर आपको कुछ कुछ फाइलें
ऐसी होती है जो डायरेक्टर के अंदर वो फाइल
है आपको देखने को मिलेंगे जो टाइम तू टाइम
चेंज होती है ठीक है जो टाइम तू टाइम चेंज
होती जैसे फूल
टेंपरेरी मेल फाइल्स है जैसे की कैचर है
डॉग्स हैं ठीक है क्या वो टाइम क्या है
अपडेट होती रहती है उसे टाइप की फाइल इसके
अंदर आपको देखने को मिलती है अगर मैं इसके
अंदर आपको जाके दिखता हूं
जो लाइब्रेरी फाइल्स है किसी भी
प्रोग्राम्स के लिए वो एक्चुअल में यहां
पर है वो वहां पर क्या सब स्पेन पे हम
क्या था शॉर्टकट किया हुआ है जब भी हम
विंडोज में कुछ किसी सॉफ्टवेयर क्रिएट कर
देता है इस टाइप से यहां पे उसका
सॉफ्टवेयर क्रिएट किया हुआ है अब है ठीक
है कुछ लोकल डाटा से रिलेटेड फाइल यहां पर
इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को यहां मिलेगी एक
यहां पर क्या है बाकी टेंपरेरी है
जब भी आप क्या हो रहा है जब भी आप अपनी
मशीन के अंदर करोगे
ना तो आपको वहां पर क्या है
तो वेब सर्वर की जो फाइल पट की जाति है वो
डायरेक्टर के अंदर की जाति है तो वो यही
पर देखने को मिलती है व्यू
उसके अंदर
फाइल से उसको जाके देखने को
मिलती है ठीक है
रन हो गया
ये आपको मैं बता चुका हूं अभी
अब कोई बैक गया क्या
दिखे रहा है एक्चुअल में क्या है ठीक है
डीएम लाइन है ठीक है कर्नल्स की फाइल्स है
मैं आपको दिखता हूं की अब मैं कैसे प्रूफ
करूंगा देखो मैं एक बार क्या करता हूं
ठीक है अभी आपको एक चीज दिखाई दे रहे हो
ये रहा अब मैंने अभी तक क्या बताया था
देखो जो बिन आपको यहां दिखाई दे रही है
एक्चुअल में क्या है वह एक शॉर्टकट है
किसका उर्स के अंदर जो बिन मैंने अभी
दिखाए था ना उसके अंदर से यहां पे एक
शॉर्टकट किया हुआ है डेस्कटॉप के ऊपर ठीक
है वहां पर इसकी रूट पार्टीशन के अंदर भूत
अपने आप में एक डायरेक्टरी है
होम अपने आप में डायरेक्टली अब ये लीजिए
आपको ये कहां से आई हुई मैं बताया था भूत
है भूत डायरेक्टरी है उसके अंदर कुछ
कंफीग्रेशन फाइल्स होते हैं देखो ये उसका
शॉर्टकट किया हुआ है बेसिकली बहुत साड़ी
ऐसी फाइल्स है जो उनके शॉर्टकट किया हुए
हैं इसके ऊपर आपके पार्टीशन के नीचे अब ये
मैंने बताया था उर्स के अंदर जो डायरेक्टर
है उसका शॉर्टकट किया हुआ है
32 आपको देखने को मिल रहा होगा लेफ्ट 64
एक इंडिविजुअल डायरेक्ट भी है मीडिया एक
इंडिविजुअल डायरेक्टली है ऐसे ही देखो
लेस्बियन यूजर से लिया
प्रोग्राम
नहीं देखने को मिलती है वो सिस्टम में कुछ
पर्टिकुलर डायरेक्ट
किया हुए हैं जिनको अगर मैं लेने एसके
टर्मिनोलॉजी में बात करूं यहां पर किसी ने
कमेंट में किया है उसको हम बोलते हैं
तो आप लिंक हार्ले ठीक है अभी जो आपको
बहुत साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन दिखाई दे रही होगी
ठीक है मेरे पास थोड़ा सा आइडिया दे देता
हूं लेकिन इसके बड़े में मैं आने वाली
क्लास में बताऊंगा यहां पर जो आपको देखने
को मिलता है ये परमीशंस है ठीक है यहां पर
आपको लिंक से इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिलती है
ये आपके यूजर्स की इनफॉरमेशन है ठीक है ये
आपके ग्रुप की इनफॉरमेशन है ये इसका साइज
है ठीक है ये इसका टाइम स्टांप है और ये
इस फाइल के डायरेक्टर का नाम है ये साड़ी
इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को मिल रही है चलो
अब हम क्या है हमारे फाइल सिस्टम
ठीक है बेसिकली आपका पता चल गया की जितनी
बात हुई थी हमारे रूट पार्टीशन के लिए
नीचे उनका एक छोटा सा इंट्रोड सुन हो गया
की पता चल गया की हां की किसके अंदर क्या
है ठीक है अब आगे से अगर आप कम करोगे ठीक
है क्योंकि मेरा अगर फर्स्ट क्लास किसी ने
अच्छी होगी आप मैक्सिमम लोगों ने अच्छी
होगी जिसने भी अच्छी होगी तो उसमें मैंने
क्या की जो कॉन्सेप्ट समझाया है उसको आप
आसानी से इसके कोलगेट कर पाओगे आने वाली
क्लासेस में
तो अब हम स्टार्ट करते हैं अपना की कैसे
हम
इजी फाइल को क्रिएट डिलीट कैसे कर सकते
हैं ठीक है
चलो स्टार्ट करते हैं अभी
मैं बहुत कम वाचिंग है यार बहुत कम लोग
हैं
ठीक है तो देखो क्या होता है आगे मुझे
क्या करना है जैसे की मुझे एलॉयज करता हूं
अभी मैं क्या करता हूं पहले अपनी ठीक है
यार अब मुझे क्या करना है की मुझे यह होम
डायरेक्टरी है मुझे इसके अंदर जाना है ठीक
है या मुझे यह जो देव डायरेक्ट फ्री है
इसके अंदर मुझे जाना है इसके अंदर जान के
लिए कमांड होती है सी दी ठीक है जो मैं
अभी तक उसे करता है सीडी का मतलब चेंज जा
रहा है मुझे क्या करना है जो ये प्रेजेंट
वर्किंग क्या है मैं रूट पार्टीशन है
बिल्कुल मैं टॉप नहीं हूं ठीक है मुझे
इससे इस डायरेक्टर के अंदर जाना है मतलब
चेंज करना है मुझे क्या लेना पड़ेगा सीडी
उसके बाद जिसके अंदर डायरेक्टर के अंदर
जाना है तो डायरेक्टर के अंदर ही जाते हैं
यहां पर फाइल का नाम नहीं दे सकते आप ओनली
डायरेक्टली का नाम दे सकते हैं तो मैंने
लिखा
जो डायरेक्टली है ना इसके अंदर चले गए
विंडो के कैसे में कैसे करते हैं हम किसी
भी फोल्डर पे डबल क्लिक करते हैं तो उसके
अंदर इंटर कर जाते हैं इस प्रकार से इसके
अंदर अगर किसी फाइल फोल्डर के अंदर अगर
आपको जाना है तो आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा
यहां पर इस कमांड का उसे करना पड़ेगा
मैंने सीडी किया
सीडी किया
मतलब अगर मुझे क्या करना है अगर मुझे यह
देखना है की इस डायरेक्टरी के अंदर कितनी
सम डायरेक्टर है मतलब फोल्डर के अंदर
कितने फोल्डर हैं और
साथ में फाइल्स कितनी है मतलब डायरेक्टर्स
कितनी है इस डायरेक्टर के अंदर देव
डायरेक्ट के अंदर ठीक है और उसके अंदर
फाइल्स कितनी है तो अगर वो इनफॉरमेशन
देखनी है उसके लिए कमांड होती है एलएस
एलएस मतलब लिस्ट कर दो इसके अंदर जो फाइल
से डायरेक्ट मिल जाएंगे इंटर कर दिया तो
अब यहां आपको देखने को मिल रहा है इसके
अंदर इतने सारे फाइल्स हो डायरेक्टरीज हैं
ठीक है इतने सारे सब डायरेक्टर्स और फाइल
से अगर मैं उसकी फॉर्म में बात करूं
फोल्डर के अंदर फोल्डर हैं और फाइल्स हैं
ठीक है ये इस डायरेक्ट के अंदर ये
इनफॉरमेशन देखने के लिए ये आपको पता चल
गया होगा अब मैं आपको बताता हूं की आप
मुझे क्या है देखिए
अंदर लेकिन देखो अब मैं एक चीज करता हूं
एक बार मैं बाहर जा रहा हूं बताता हूं
अब मैं एक बार
अब मैं क्या करता हूं देखो अभी मैं क्या
हूं की अगर आपको कोई पूछे की प्रेजेंट
वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी आपकी क्या है तभी मेरी
क्या है यह प्रेजेंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी
है प पीडी ठीक है देखो क्या है की अब मुझे
लेटेस्ट मशीन है ठीक है हमारी लेटेस्ट
मशीन है तो आपको ये क्या है
पूरा फूल पार्ट दिखा रही है अब यहां पर ये
कॉन्सेप्ट आता है ठीक है क्या कॉन्सेप्ट
आता है मैं बताऊंगा लेकिन सबसे पहले मैं
एक चीज बता देता हूं देखो क्या है की अभी
मुझे यह देखना की इसका फूल पाठ क्या है
एक्चुअल में जो डाउनलोड फोल्डर है यह
हमारे मशीन में हमारे फाइल सिस्टम में है
कहां पर ठीक है
यहां पर गैस कर का रहा हूं लेकिन कुछ ऐसी
मशीन होगी अगर आप रेड की मशीन उसे करेंगे
पुरानी यूनिक मशीन उसे करके वहां पर गैस
नहीं कर पाओगे वापस सिर्फ करंट वर्किंग
डायरेक्टरी है उसको देख पाओगे तो ये रहा
करंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी यहां पर देख
पाओगे ये रहा डाउनलोड से| अगर मुझे ये
देखना है की फूल पौधा देखना है की जी
डायरेक्टर के अंदर अब मैं हूं उसका फूल
पाठ क्या है वो देखने के लिए एक पीडी
कमांड होती है प्रेजेंट वर्किंग
आईटी इंटर कर दिया तो आपको देखने को मिल
जाएगी अगर रूट के अंदर फॉरवर्ड स्लाइस
क्या है फ्रूट पार्टीशन उसके अंदर मेरा
होम अकाउंट है रूट का ठीक है और उसके अंदर
एक डाउनलोड नाम की एक डायरेक्टर है जिसके
अंदर मैं हूं ये मेरा क्या है फूल बात है
ठीक है पीडी में करता हूं ठीक है तो ये
इसका फूल पास शो करता है
अब मैं क्या करता हूं पहले करता हूं कुछ
नहीं है
अब मुझे क्या करना है मैं आपको एक
कॉन्सेप्ट बता अभी यहां पर क्या इंडिकेशन
ए गया
होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर हूं एक कॉन्सेप्ट
आता है यहां पर आपका एब्सलूट पाठ और
एब्सलूट पाठ और लेट हो पास अगर मैं अगर
बताऊंगा आपको
इसी बता देता हूं एक कॉन्सेप्ट आता है
आपका
मतलब क्या होता है
उसके अंदर डाउनलोड
ठीक है और एक होता है दूसरा आपका होता है
दूसरा एक और बात होता है
की वो फूल पास नहीं होता ठीक है
अब मुझे क्या करना यहां से डाउनलोड
डायरेक्टर
के अंदर जाना है यहां से मैं दो तरीके से
जा सकता हूं यह तो एब्सलूट पाठ डीके या
रिलेटिव पाठ डीके बट क्या है की
एब्सलूट पाठ देखें तो आप क्या है ना किसी
भी डायरेक्टर के अंदर जा सकते हो कहानी से
भी यही से बैठे आप कहानी किसी भी
डायरेक्टर के अंदर जा सकते हो बट क्या है
एब्सलूट पाठ देकर अब मैं रिलेटिव पास से
ऐसा नहीं कर सकता है की प्रेजेंट करके
वर्ल्ड किंग जो डायरेक्टली है इससे आगे
मुझे अगर किसी डायरेक्टर के अंदर जाना है
तो मजा ए सकता हूं वो है अब मुझे इस
डाउनलोड डायरेक्ट करें अंदर जाना है तो
सिंपली मैं कैसे करूंगा मैंने सीडी किया
और डाउनलोड किया मैंने डाउनलोड और इंटर कर
दिया इसके अंदर चला गया तो ये मैंने उसे
किया
अगर मुझे एब्सलूट पाठ करना होता है ना उसे
करने के लिए मैं आपको दिखता हूं अब सिर्फ
इसका एब्सलूट पाठ ये है अब्सोल पाठ उसे
करता हूं मैं कैसे करता
सीडी करता उसके बाद कंट्रोल शिफ्ट भी ठीक
है ये मेरा क्या है एब्सलूट पाठ है ये
मेरा एब्सलूट पाठ है मैंने मतलब की मुझे
क्या करना है रूट के अंदर एक डायरेक्टरी
है डाउनलोड उसके अंदर जाना है तो ये टेंडर
किया है मैंने ये रहा अब मैं चला गया फिर
भी इस के अंदर ए गया जैसे ये दो तरीके थे
अब मैं अब्सोल पढ़ के एग्जांपल दिखता हूं
देखो अभी तो मैं क्या इस होम डायरेक्टरी
के अंदर हूं ठीक है अब मैं क्या करता हूं
साइड में
मुझे क्या करना है की
अब मुझे हां इसका मतलब समझता हूं अगर मुझे
अपने रूट पार्टी जाना है ठीक है तो सिंपली
सीडी किया रूट पार्टीशन पे चला गया अगर
मुझे डायरेक्टली क्या करना है अगर मुझे
डायरेक्टली क्या करना है होम डायरेक्टरी
में जाना है तो मैं सीडी करूंगा चेंज
डायरेक्टली और होम डायरेक्टरी के लिए यह
सिंबल उसे करूंगा तब भी मैंने होम
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर चला जाऊंगा फिर से अगर
मुझे क्या करना है क्योंकि अब मैं लास्ट
टाइम की इसमें था रूट पार्टीशन के अंदर था
लेकिन अभी मैं प्रेजेंट में मेरी क्या है
ये है तो अगर मुझे
पीछे वाले डायरेक्टर में जाना है तो मैं
कैसे जाऊंगा उसका तो सीडी किया मैंने और
मैंने क्या कर दिया मैंने
जो प्रीवियस कमांड पे जो डायरेक्टर चलती
थी मतलब प्रीवियस कमांड में मेरा जो जो
कमांड दे दी सीडी फॉरवर्ड स्लाइस उसपे चला
जाऊंगा सीधी इंटर कर दिया देखो अब मैं
क्या है प्रीवियस कमांड मेरे क्या थी मैं
इस पे था ठीक है बेसिकली जब मैंने सीडी
दास किया फिर ये किया गया उसको प्रीवियस
कमांडर उसने क्या कर दिया बैंड कर दी
प्रीवियस कमांड में क्या था सीडी 4 अब फिर
से मैंने क्या किया लो उससे प्रीवियस
कमांड
ठीक है बहुत अच्छे से कम करते हैं अब आपको
मैं दिखता हूं एब्सलूट पाठ का तरीका कैसे
करना है एमडी करता हूं मैं एक बार
मुझे क्या करना है
होम डायरेक्टरी है मेरी मैंने रूट की जो
होम डायरेक्टरी अभी जो डाउनलोड के अंदर
जाना है मुझे ठीक है अब आप सिंपल है मैंने
सीडी किया और डाउनलोड
डायरेक्टली है नहीं क्योंकि भैया ये आपने
रिलेटिव पाठ उसे किया है ये यहां पे इसको
समझ में नहीं आया मशीन को ठीक है तो अब
इसको समझने के लिए क्या करना पड़ेगा आपको
यहां पर एब्सलूट पाठ देना है एब्सलूट मतलब
क्या है की ये डाउनलोड डायरेक्टली है क्या
मुझे क्या करना है सीडी करना है डाउनलोड
डायरेक्टली क्या है रूट डायरेक्टर के अंदर
यहां पर डाउनलोड
आई होप सबको एब्सलूट पाठ और ये दोनों चेंज
क्लियर हो गई होगी आप लोगों को ठीक है अब
बात करते हैं कंटिन्यू नेक्स्ट आपको दिखता
हूं मैं अब
की
एक कमांड है मेरी एलएस एलएस किया मैंने
अब एक चीज दिखा दो हर एक डायरेक्टर है ना
कितनी भी डायरेक्टली
मिलेगा
ही मिलेगा इनका मतलब क्या होता है
आपका करंट वर्किंग करंट डायरेक्टरी ठीक है
करंट डायरेक्टरी होता है आपका सिंगल डोर
और जो है डबल डॉट होता है ये होता है जो
करंट डायरेक्टरी है ना ये उसका ये
रिप्रेजेंट करता है उसकी पैरंट डायरेक्टरी
को मतलब क्या है की जो सिंगल डॉट के अंदर
करंट डायरेक्टर का एड्रेस और होता है और
जो डबल डॉट है होता है इसके इसके अंदर जो
इसकी प्रीवियस डायरेक्टर
उसे किया हिट और देखो मैं कहां पर ए गया
रूट के अंदर आया क्योंकि अगर माटी पीडी
करता हूं देखो अब रूट के अंदर ही हूं
क्योंकि उसका होम अकाउंट है तो इसलिए यहां
पर जो एड्रेस और होता है वो किसका होता है
उसके पेरेंट्स का अंडरस्टोर होता है और ये
डॉट है इसके करंट उसका स्टोर होता है यहां
भी आपको देखने को मिलेगा क्योंकि हमेशा
हिडन मिलेगा आपको देखने को देखो हार्ड
ड्राइव के अंदर देखना पड़ेगा
हिडेंस होते हैं ठीक है हिडन फाइल्स होती
है तो हिडन डायरेक्टली होती है सॉरी तो ये
आपको देखने को मिल रहा होगा तो ये एक छोटी
सी इनफॉरमेशन थी आप लोगों के लिए अब मैं
थोड़ा सा आपको एलएस कमांड के बड़े में
बताता हूं ठीक है ल एस कमांड के बड़े में
थोड़ा सा आपको इन्फो देता हूं बताता हूं
ठीक है
मैं लिस्टिंग करता है अब मुझे क्या करना
है किसी पर्टिकुलर डायरेक्टली के अंदर की
फाइल से यार सब डायरेक्टर को देखना तो मैं
कैसे देख सकता हूं तो मैंने क्या किया और
मैं क्या करना एटीसी के अंदर जितने भी
डायरेक्टर हैं ठीक है
ठीक है इंटर कर दिया अब इसने क्या कर दिया
लिस्ट आउट कर दिया की इसके अंदर जो एटीसी
डायरेक्ट है इसके अंदर जितनी फाइल्स हैं
उसकी इनफॉरमेशन को उसने लिस्ट आउट कर दिया
ठीक है अब नेक्स्ट फ्लैग नेक्स्ट फ्लैग
कौन सा उसे कर सकते हैं एलएस के साथ की
अगर मुझे क्या करना है की जो ईटीसी
डायरेक्ट हो सकता है इसके अंदर कोई हिडन
फाइल छुपो ठीक है हो सकता है कोई हिडन
फाइल्स भी नहीं होगी अगर वो इनफॉरमेशन
देखनी है वो मैं कैसे देखूंगा
एलएस ठीक है
और मैं फिर से मैंने ईटीसी कर दिया ठीक है
और कर दिया अब फिर इसमें क्या कर दिया शो
कर दिया देखो जरा अब ये क्या कर दिया इसने
हाइडल फाइल के साथ
ये दो वाली तार ए गई ठीक है उसके साथ इसने
क्या कर दिया वो रिजल्ट आपके स्क्रीन पे
शो कर दिया एक और चीज होती है हम इसके साथ
करता हूं सिंपली मैं चाहूं अगर मैंने अब
सिंपली
अब मैंने सिंपली हिटलर कर दिया विदाउट कोई
पास दिए तो मतलब ये लिस्ट आउट करेगा जो
प्रेजेंट वर्किंग बैटरी है उसके अंदर की
जो इनफॉरमेशन है उसको क्या रहेगा शो करेगा
हिट इंटर कर दिया प्रेजेंट वर्किंग
डायरेक्टरी है उसके अंदर की इसमें क्या
कहानी इनफॉरमेशन शो कर दिया हिफिन ल मतलब
इसने क्या है उसके बड़े में जो पर्टिकुलर
फाइल सी या डायरेक्टली उसकी डिटेल
इनफॉरमेशन को आपके सामने शो किया
इनफॉरमेशन कैसे उसका मटर डाटा देखो उसके
ऊपर क्या परमीशंस हैं ठीक है उसका क्या
साइज है उसका यूजर कौन है वो वो किस ग्रुप
का पार्ट है ठीक है वो कब क्रिएट किया गया
था उसे फाइल का नाम क्या है ये साड़ी
इनफॉरमेशन इसके साथ देखने में लगी है अगर
इन फ्लेक्स को एक साथ भी उसे कर सकते हैं
ल एस किया अगर मैं इसकी हिडन फाइल को
देखूंगा एलएस आईफोन ए ल किया तो ये भी कर
सकता हूं इंटर अब इसने क्या कर दिया जो
इसके अंदर देखो वैसे तो चार-पांच दिखे रही
थी अब देखिए कितनी साड़ी फाइल्स डायरेक्ट
देखने में क्योंकि इसके अंदर बहुत साड़ी
ऐसी फाइल जो इंडियन फाइल थी देखो ये रही
ये आपकी हिडन फाइल्स की इनफॉरमेशन आपके
सामने ए गई ठीक है तो पता चल गया की एलएस
का मां को कैसे उसे करना है आप लोगों को
हां एक और एक चीज बताता हूं आपको अगर आपको
नहीं पता की इस कमांड को कैसे उसे करना है
बूटेबल कमांड को कैसे उसे करना है तो हर
एक कमांड के हेल्प फाइल होती है और मैंने
हेल्प फाइल कैसे देखते हैं मैंने कमांड का
नाम लिखा उसके बाद मैंने लिखा आईफोन पल
लिखोगे हिट अंदर कर दिया तो इसने लिख दिया
की जो कमांड है क्या करती है इसके साथ आप
कौन-कौन से फ्लैग उसे कर सकते हो इस कमांड
को कैसे उसे कर सकते हो कमांड का नाम उसके
साथ आप फ्लैग उसे करेगा ऑप्शन उसे करोगे
उसके बाद फाइल का नाम ठीक है उसके बाद
लिखा की लिस्ट इनफॉरमेशन अबाउट डी फाइल्स
ठीक है उसके बाद शॉर्ट और वृक्ष
अल्फाबेटिकल ओके
नोट एंट्रीज अल्फाबेटिकल अब इसके ये सारे
वो ऑप्शन जिसके साथ हिफिन ए उसे किया था
जो ठीक है आईफोन ए मतलब जो हिडन फाइल
इंक्लूडिंग हैपन कैपिटल ए का ऑलमोस्ट रोल
हिफिन बी ब्लॉक वाली कैपिटल बी ये साड़ी
चीज हैं बहुत सारे फ्लेक्स होते हैं
कॉमनली जो उसे होने देते हैं मैंने आपको
दिखा दिया है फ्रेंड अगर ओनली डायरेक्टली
इसको देखना चाहता है किसी फाइल की अगर आप
अंदर ओनली डायरेक्टरी को इंस्टॉल करना
चाहते हैं तो वो भी आप देख सकते हो ठीक है
आईफोन है ओनली फाइल्स को देखना चाहते हो
ठीक है आईफोन
देखना चाहते हो उसके तो वो भी देख सकते हो
की वहां पर कब में जो साइज का साइज दिखे
रहा होगा फाइल का वो बी में दिखेगा ठीक है
ये आपको देखने को मिल गया मतलब इतने सारे
ऑप्शंस इसके साथ उसे हो सकते हैं ठीक है
तो ये इतने सारे ऑप्शंस इसके बड़े में
हेल्प मेनू इसकी यही ब्यूटी है की आपको
अगर कमांड का नाम पता है उसको उसे करना
नहीं आता उसकी सिंपली हेल्प फाइल होती है
हेल्प फाइल देखो उसके फ्लैग को उसे कर लो
वो आपको समझ में ए जाएगी हां एक और चीज
होती है अगर आपको ज्यादा डिटेल इनफॉरमेशन
पढ़नी है किसी भी पर्टिकुलर कमांड एक
कमांड होती है
अभी आपको देख पाओगे की यह पुरी की पुरी
इसकी
मैन्युअल है ठीक है मतलब एक किताब है
इसमें सब कुछ लिखा और भी ज्यादा डिटेल के
साथ आप चाहे तो ये पेपर कर सकते हो और ये
कमांड की होती है ये ल फाइल पर्सनल
मैन्युअल फाइल अगर आपको कहानी बाहर कहानी
एक्सट्रैक्ट हो जाते हैं आपको समझ में
नहीं आता आपको क्या टास्क करना है क्या
नहीं करना है तो वो आप इसकी हेल्प से कर
सकते हो देख सकते हो ठीक है अब बात करते
हैं लाइनेक्स में एक ऑटो कंप्लीशन चीज
बहुत अच्छी चीज है कैसे देखो क्या होता है
की अगर आपको हर बार तो लेंस में वो याद
नहीं रहेगी डायरेक्टर या फाइल्स ठीक है
लेकिन ऑटो कंप्लीशन क्या होता है की आपको
इतना याद है की यार हां इस डायरेक्टरी के
अंदर नहीं है दी नाम से या दी ए नाम से
कोई ज्यादा डायरेक्टली हो सकता है ओके ठीक
है अभी मैंने किया है ठीक है अब मुझे इतना
पता है की ये है इसमें दी नाम की
डायरेक्टरी या दी ओ सी है डाक आपको इतना
याद नहीं पता है दी ओ सी करके कुछ आइडिया
डायरेक्ट मुझे वो उसके अंदर जाना है ठीक
है सिंपली क्या करो आपने क्या कर दिया
चेंज करना है इसके अंदर आपको अब क्या है
की यहां आप उसे करोगे दी मैं यहां रिलेटिव
पाठ उसे कर रहा हूं क्योंकि यहां पर मैं
उसे कर सकता हूं अभी हमने दी उसे कर लिया
अब क्या है की जैसे ही अभी तो ये क्या शो
कर रहा है इसकी ब्यूटी है एडरवाइज क्या है
या जैसे आप तब मारोगे देखो तब मारते ही
आपको दिखा देगा हां दी से भैया नहीं आपकी
इस मशीन में एक तो डेस्कटॉप है एक
डॉक्यूमेंट एक डाउनलोड ओके बोला आपको
क्लियर हो गया की कौन सा उसे करना है
उसमें सिंपली जो दी उसके क्लिक कर डॉग तो
सिंपली जाओगे तो तब भी ये क्या है ये हो
जाएगा नहीं तो अब दी ओ करोगे आपको पता
चलेगा दी और सी क्रिया है आपने अब इतना
याद है अब आपने फिर तप मार दिया तब मारते
क्या कर दिया इसने क्या कहते हैं ऑटो
कंप्लीट कर देगा ये इसको क्या कर देगा ऑटो
कंप्लीट कर दिया मतलब आपको हर बार पूरा
नाम लिखने की जरूर नहीं पड़ेगी अब क्या है
की आप साइबर सिक्योरिटी मोर ले नेक्स्ट
साइड में हो अगर आपको ऑटो कंप्लीशन नहीं
करना आता तो दिन भर आपके पास पुरी चीज
टाइप करते रहोगे सिंपली क्या करो ये टेंडर
कर दिया अब मुझे सीडी बैक गया अब मुझे
क्या कर दिया फिर से मैं गया और मैंने दो
सी की मार दिया लो तो कंप्लीट हो गया
फटाफट कम हो रहे हैं ठीक है एडरवाइज क्या
है दी ओ सी की स्पेलिंग गलत हुई तो आपको
फिर भी क्या है गड़बड़ होगी क्यों गड़बड़
हो गई क्योंकि नेक्स्ट कैसे सेंसेटिव है
ठीक है
आप उसे कर रहे हो जी मशीन को ठीक है अभी
मैं आपको चीज सीखना हूं की आप किसी भी
डायरेक्टर को कैसे क्रिएट कर सकते हो ठीक
है किसी भी डायरेक्टली को आप कैसे क्रिएट
कर सकते हो
एक कमांड
होती है
उसके बाद आप लिख दीजिए उसे डायरेक्टर का
नाम जो उसे रखना चाहते हैं जैसे मैं
डायरेक्टर का नाम रखना चाहता हूं
इसने क्या कर दी अब वो डायरेक्टली क्रिएट
कर दिया अगर वो देखना है तो मैंने एलएस
किया तो यहां पर आपको देखने को मिलेगा हां
कैप्सूल कोर्स नाम की डायरेक्टरी आपकी
क्रिएट हो गई ठीक है
मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं एक बैटरी बनाना
चाहता हूं जिसका नाम क्या रखना चाहता हूं
यूनिक्स यूनिक्स ये नाम रखना चाहता हूं अब
ये कैसे क्रिएट करूंगा अब यहां बैठे बैठे
करूंगा मैं ना की मैं पहले सीडी करूंगा
बाहर जाऊंगा टीएनपी डायरेक्टर करूंगा नहीं
अब मैं कैसे करूंगा मैं सिंपली क्या है एम
के दी यार किया मैंने और उन पांच दूंगा
हां भैया टी एमपी के अंदर ठीक है एक यूनिक
नाम का मुझे क्या करना है एक डायरेक्टली
क्रिएट करनी है ठीक है और मैंने हिट इंटर
कर दिया अभी इसने क्या किया की टीएनपी के
अंदर यूनिक्स नाम की डायरेक्टर को क्रिएट
कर दिया अगर आप क्रॉस चेक करना है तो लो
मैं एलएस करता हूं इधर से बैठा मेरा चेक
कर लूंगा ये एमपी के अंदर गया और मैंने कर
दिया 800 कर दिया ये देखो ये एमपी के अंदर
यूनिक्स नाम पे डायरेक्टली इसके अंदर इसने
क्रिएट कर दी अब एक और चीज है अब आपको
क्या करना है आप चाहते हो की मुझे
यूनिक्स वन के अंदर एक है
पी ओ एम टॉम नाम के डायरेक्टर
होता है
हिट इंटर करूंगा अब इसमें क्रिएट कर दिया
पी का मतलब होता है पेरेंट्स चाइल्ड
रिलेशनशिप को आप मेंटेन करते हुए
डायरेक्टली क्रिएट कर दीजिए बोल ये बोल
रहा है की भाई टीएनपी के अंदर पहले चेक
यूनिक है नहीं है तो क्रिएट कर दो लाइन है
नहीं है तो क्रिएट कर दो तो हम क्रिएट
करनी है तो इसने क्या कर दिया ये सब कर
दिया अगर मैं अगर आपको दिखाऊं एलएस करके
पंप हिट हंटर देखो इसने यूनिक्स वन वीक
रीड कर दिया पहले क्रिएट नहीं कर कर मैं
यूनिक्स वन के अंदर भी दिखाऊंगा अगर मैं
टीएनपी उसके बाद यूनिक्स वन आपको दिखाऊं
800 करके देखो इसके अंदर लेने कर दिया
किसी भी डायरेक्टर को कैसे रिमूव करते हैं
किसी भी डायरेक्टरी को कैसे रिमूव करते
हैं
रिक्रूट को रिमूव करने के लिए कमांड होती
है आम
और मैंने क्या करती है
ठीक है अगर यह डायरेक्टली एम्टी है तो अब
ये अभी डिलीट हो जाएगी ठीक है एम्टी
डायरेक्ट है तो ये डिलीट हो जाएगी तो एम
के दी आई आर सॉरी रम रिमूव डायरेक्टरी ठीक
है और
सिंपली और उसके बाद मैं डायरेक्टरी का नाम
इपून कैप्सूल ठीक है अभी टेंडर कर दिया
मैंने इसमें क्या कर दिया इसको डिलीट कर
दिया रिमूव डायरेक्टली कर दिया अब मुझे
क्या करना है अब मुझे स्ट्रांग वाली
डायरेक्टर को डिलीट करना है तो कैसे
करूंगा वो भी है यार करूंगा उसके बाद
करूंगा यूनिक्स वन करूंगा ठीक है
मुझे क्या करना है
मुझे क्या करना है मुझे
डिलीट करना
है
यार करना है उसके बाद मैं क्या किया
उसके बाद मैंने क्या किया यूनिक बट मैं ये
वाली क्रेडिट करना था डिलीट करना चाहता
हूं सॉरी अब इंटर कर दिया ये बोला फेल तू
बिकॉज़ क्योंकि डायरेक्टली हम टी नहीं है
अगर डायरेक्टली हम टी नहीं है तो आप आराम
दे यार कमांड से डिलीट नहीं कर सकते उसके
लिए आपको उसे करना पड़ेगा ठीक है आरंभ
कमांडो को आपको उसे करना याद रहा आपको फूल
पद डीके उसको दे पहले इसको डिलीट करना
होगा उसके बाद आपको यूनिक वन को एडिट करना
होगा ठीक है
तो उसके बाद अब इसके लिए मुझे कैसे का
सकता हूं उसके लिए कमांड होती है आराम ठीक
है रिमूव आईफोन आर मतलब
ठीक है उसके बाद मैं क्या करूंगा
ठीक है
इसको डिलीट कर दिया ठीक है अभी ये क्या
करता है ये फोर्स बहुत ही पावरफुल कमांड
है मैं आप लोगों को एक एडवाइस करूंगा यहां
पर की अगर आपको ठीक है
अगर इस कमांड के साथ अगर आप हैंडसम नहीं
हो अगले उसके साथ अगर हैंडसम नहीं हो तो
प्लीज डोंट प्रेफर दिस कमांड ठीक है इस
कमांड को उसे करने की कोशिश मत करना
क्योंकि इतनी खतरनाक कमांड है अगर आपने
अपने पाठ में कोई भी गड़बड़ कर दी तो आपके
पूरे के पूरे सिस्टम को ये उदा देगी कैसे
की अगर जैसे की आप एक बेगिनेर हो आपने ठीक
है कमांड से उसे कर लिया हिफिन आर एफ की
अब आपने दिया है उसके वो कहानी ध्यान से
स्पेस डब गया अपने फिर टीएनपी दे दिया ठीक
है आपको तो पता नहीं है अब यूं लिख दे
दिया ठीक है यूनिक्स
दे दिया अब भैया देखो क्या होता है
फर्स्ट जो आपका आर्गुमेंट है क्योंकि ये
क्या है ना सारे के सारे आर्गुमेंट में
अकाउंट होते हैं ठीक है जब फर्स्ट कोई
मानता है कमांड है बाकी के अलावा जितनी भी
स्पेस सेपरेट चीज है ना उनको ये आर्गुमेंट
समझना है अब इसने यहां तक समझ लिया इसके
बाद इसने क्या सोचा ओ ये मतलब ये क्या है
रूट पार्टीशन आपका ठीक है उसके पास स्पेस
है अब इसके सर्विस का ध्यान ही नहीं जाएगा
क्योंकि इसमें क्या कहते हैं जैसे इसको
करेगा
फाइल सिस्टम को ये उदा देगा डिलीट कर देगा
उससे क्या है आपको बिल्कुल भी कोई बेनिफिट
है नहीं होने वाला ठीक है और ये आपने
सिस्टम को करके
कमांड को उसे कर रहे हो जब तक आप इसके साथ
फैमिली हो जाए तो आप इसके साथ हैंड ही
नहीं हो जो तो आप ये कोशिश मत करना ये
करने की ठीक है
यहां तक आप लोगों को समझ में ए गया होगा
अब मैं बात करता हूं अपने अगर आपको किसी
लेंस के अंदर किसी भी फाइल को अगर क्रिएट
करना तो कैसे कर सकते हो फाइल को क्रिएट
करने के लिए बहुत साड़ी कमांड होती है कैट
भी होती है ठीक है एक कमांडर भी होती है
ठीक है और टच कमांड होती है बहुत साड़ी
फैमिली ठीक है लेकिन मैं क्या करता हूं
अभी
टच कमांड से रिलेटेड करके दिखता हूं आपके
फाइल को ठीक है
टच किया और मैंने क्या कर दिया ओके इसके
अंदर मैंने क्रिएट किया थे
उसे कर रहा हूं बेसिकली देखो टच कमांड का
क्या एक फीचर है ये लेकिन टच का यह में
प्रपोज नहीं है
जैसे की आपको मैं बताता हूं जो टच कमांड
है ना उसके तीन-चार फीचर्स हैं तीन कर
फीचर्स हैं
लोग बोलते हैं की टच कमांड का उसे किया
जाता है
कोई भी फाइल क्रिएट करता है तो स्पेशली वो
कुछ कम करने के लिए करता है उसके लिए बहुत
सारे नैनो है अभी मैं भी आई है ठीक है और
वो भी बहुत सारे हैं जिनके साथ कैट कमांड
से भी वो क्या कर सकता है उनको क्रिएट कर
सकता है बट लेकिन टच कमांड में क्या है टच
कमांड का बेसिक परपज क्या है टाइम स्टांप
को अपडेट करना में परपज क्या है टाइम को
अपडेट करना ठीक है मैं आपको अगर लिख के
दिखा रहा हूं
तू अपडेट
टाइम
को बेसिकली अपडेट करना होता है
ठीक है अब क्या है
इस टाइम को अपडेट करने के लिए ठीक है अब
जब भी कोई फाइल क्रिएट
फाइल को कब देखा गया था कम खोल गया था और
कब इस फाइल को एक्सेस किया जाता है बेसिक
मतलब ये है अब सेकंड
लेकिन जो चीज जुड़नी है इसके साथ वह एकदम
मॉडिफाइड है
मतलब की लास्ट टाइम इस फाइल को कम मॉडिफाई
किया था कब इसमें कुछ भी एडिट किया गया था
कुछ भी डाटा एड किया गया था कब लास्ट टाइम
को एडिट किया गया था दूसरा है ये
इसी चीज कौन सी जुड़नी है वो तीसरी जो चीज
होती है उसको हम बोलते हैं चेंज टाइम
का मतलब क्या है
[संगीत]
की लास्ट टाइम
भी अगर आपने फाइल की लोकेशन चेंज की ठीक
है
परमिशन चेंज हुई तब उसका डाटा चेंज होता
फाइल के बड़े में उसकी परमीशंस है उसके वह
कहां पर स्टोर होती है ठीक है मतलब बेसिक
उसके इनफॉरमेशन होती है उसके बड़े में
उसका साइज क्या है उसका नाम क्या है उसका
वो मेटल डाटा होता है तो वो लास्ट टाइम कम
चेंज किया था ये तीन चीज इसके साथ क्या हो
जाति है किसी भी फाइल के साथ अब मुझे ये
तीन चीजों की इनफॉरमेशन देखनी है उसके लिए
कमांड होती है स्टेट स्टेटस होती है
उसके बाद आप फाइल का नाम
लिखा था आज की डेट है अभी का टाइम है ठीक
है और इतने सेकंड में ये इसका मॉडिफाइड
टाइम्स शो कर रहा है ये उसका चेंज टाइम शो
कर रहा है ये इसका बर्थ टाइम शो कर रहा है
कभी ये फाइल
और फैमिली
की अब मैं टच कमांड के फीचर्स को उसे कर
सकता हूं मैं क्या कर सकता हूं इस टाइम
स्पेंड को एक साथ तीनों को भी चेंज कर
सकता हूं या एक-एक टाइम को और मॉडिफाई
टाइम को चेंज कर सकता हूं ठीक है चेंज
चेंज कमांड चेंज टाइम को मैं चेंज नहीं कर
सकता ठीक है अब अपने आप चेंज होता है बॉडी
एक्सेस के साथ या मॉडिफाई के साथ ठीक है
और यह मैं पर्टिकुलर शैंपू चेंज कर सकता
हूं तो अब मैं टच कमांड से मल्टीपल फाइल
भी क्रिएट कर सकता हूं कैसे जैसे की मैं
लेने था मैंने लाइनेक्स वन किया उसके बाद
लाइनेक्स किया और लाइनेक्स फ्री कर दिया
मल्टीप्लाई मल्टीपल एम्टी फाइल उसने
क्रेडिट कर दिया ठीक है अब मैं एक चीज
दिखता हूं मैं मेरे पास कुछ टाइम स्टांप
है मैंने अभी किया 1 मिनट में सीडी देता
हूं
और हिटलर किया
उसके बाद फाइल वन का टाइम टाइम ठीक है
मैं
इसका अगर तीनों का अगर मैं चेंज करना
चाहता हूं इस फाइल बैंड का ठीक है तीनों
ही टाइम चेंज करना चाहता हूं तो सिंपली
मैं क्या करूंगा
अब देखना अब मैं इसका टाइम देखो अभी के
साथ इसका
पूरा पूरा टाइम अपडेट हो गया ठीक है अगर
मुझे क्या करना है ओनली एक्सेस टाइम को
मैंने क्या करना है अपडेट करना ओनली
एक्सेस टाइम को तो कैसे अपडेट करूंगा मैं
मैं क्या करूंगा सिंपली जब मैं एक बार
स्टेट काम लेट हूं
फाइल तू बैक सिस्टम अब ये इसका है अब मैं
फाइल तू का ओनली एक्सेस टाइम चेंज करना
चाहता हूं कैसे करूंगा मैं टच किया तो क
टच से उसके बाद हिफिन ए मतलब एक्सिस टाइम
को और उसे फाइल का नाम दे दिया है सिंपली
मैंने फाइल
अंदर कर दिया अब मैं इसको फिर से आपको
दिखता हूं तो ये इसका ओनली देखो एक्सेस
टाइम चेंज हुआ है और चेंज टाइम मतलब इसको
जब भी एक्सेस किया है तो उसको तीन टाइम हो
गया बाकी मॉडिफाई टाइम चेंज नहीं हुआ अगर
मैं मॉडिफाई चेंज टाइम चेंज करना चाहूं
किसी पार्टिकल फाइल का वो कैसे करूंगा वो
थर्ड वाली फाइल पे दिखता हूं तो मैंने
क्या किया टच किया और आईफोन एम किया एक
लाइक उसे किया और मैंने उसको फाइल का
मैंने नाम लिखा फाइल थ्री ठीक है
अब मैं इसको स्टेट कर दिखता हूं थ्री का
तो आपको देखने को मिलेगा की ओनली मतलब हर
बार क्या आएगी चेंज
मेटल डाटा चेंज टाइम है वो कैसा है
क्योंकि आप भी जब भी फाइल में कुछ भी
मोडिफिकेशन करो कुछ भी करो तो ऑटोमेटेकली
अपडेट होगा तो ये क्या है ये दोनों अपडेट
हो गए लेकिन ये अभी एक्सेस टाइम नहीं हुआ
तो ये थे टच कमांड के फिर से हम कैसे उसे
कर सकते हैं बेसिकली करता हूं अपनी होम
डायरेक्टरी में चला जाता हूं अब मैं आपको
एक चीज दिखा रहा था की कैट कमांड से भी
कैसे कर सकते हैं कैट का मतलब होता है
कंटेंट को रेड करने के लिए उसे किया जाता
है अगर मैं पास मैंने कोई फाइल है ये अभी
एक बार मैं करता हूं पहले ओके अगर मैं एक
चीज दिखाऊंगा कैट कमांड कर सकता हूं वो
दिखता हूं अगर मैंने क्या किया कैट ठीक है
ग्रेटर डेन ग्रेटर दें साइन ठीक है इसका
मैं बताऊंगा क्या मतलब ये रिडक्शन सिंबल
होता है और मैंने फाइल का नाम लिखा यहां
पर मैं क्या का रहा हूं फाइल
फाइल लिखा और
लिख दिया मैंने और कर दिया अब यहां पर
क्या होगा आपका ये
स्टॉप हो गया मतलब अब क्या है की फाइल
क्रिएट हो गई भैया अब आप इसके अंदर जो भी
कुछ लिखोगे ना वो आप लिख पाओगे मैं लिखा
दिस इसे
न्यू ए ठीक है दिस इसे न्यू फाइव
[संगीत]
तो ये है उसका न्यू फाइल और मैंने ये
तंत्र कर दिया फिर अब नेक्स्ट लाइन ए गया
जब तक मैं इसको क्या है कंट्रोल दी नहीं
करूंगा तब तक ये बैंड नहीं होगी अब मैं
करके दिखता हूं और अब मुझे क्या करना है
इसके कंटेंट को रीड करना है मुझे इसके
अंदर क्या लिखा हुआ है तो क्या लिखूंगा
मैं उसके लिए
इंटर कर दिया
तो इस तरीके से कैट कमांड को भी आप क्या
है फाइल क्रिएट करने के लिए उसे कर सकते
हैं और अंदर के कंटेंट को पढ़ने के लिए भी
कट कमांड को आप उसे कर सकते हैं अगर आप
किसी दो फाइल्स का
डाटा अगर वो करना चाहते हो की एक फाइल में
क्या करना चाहते कांटेक्ट करना चाहते हो
कैट का कमांड का मतलब क्या होता है
कांटेक्ट करना चाहते तो वह भी आप कर सकते
हो
वह यहां पर कर सकते हो उसका कोई नहीं है
क्या करोगे कैट के साथ दोनों फाइल का नाम
उसे करोगे उसके बाद लेटर देना साइन का उसे
करोगे तो एक बार कैसे की जैसे मैंने एक और
फाइल क्रिएट
की मैंने और रिटर्न सिंबल और
पायल डॉट फाइल
किया ये टेंडर
फाइल के अंदर दाल दिया फाइल रीडर
अब इसके अंदर दोनों लाइन आपकी एड हो गई
फाइलों कैसे रिमूव करते हैं ठीक है फाइल
को रिमूव कैसे करते हैं तो उसके लिए कमांड
होती है आराम ठीक है उसके बाद क्या है या
तो फूल पद दो या एब्सलूट पर एब्सलूट पाठ
दो या रिलेटिव पाठ दो ठीक है रिलेटिव पाठ
कब जाना आपको पता है रिमूव किया है मुझे
किसको फाइल
वन डॉट टी एक्स तू को मैंने क्या करना है
तो सिंपली रिमूव कर दिया ठीक है आम कमांड
अगर फाइल तू डीएक्सट को मुझे रिमूव करना
है तो उसको तब किया तू डीएक्सट
रिक्रूटमेंट रिमूव
ठीक है
एक वीडियो फाइल नहीं है
तो मैं क्या करूंगा
रिटर्न कर दिया
उसे कर सकते हो हिफिन हिफिन हेल्प इसकी भी
हेल्प फाइल आप देख सकते हो
आईफोन अप का मतलब फोर्सफुली आईफोन अगर आप
आईफोन आई उसे करोगे हमेशा ट्राई करोगे आप
जब रिमूव कर दो आई उसे कर लो अगर आप एक
बैग इंडिया हो की आपको मिल जाएगी सच में
आप उसे फाइल को क्या करना चाहते हो डिलीट
करना चाहते हैं भाई मिस्टेक के लिए आप कर
रहे हो सोने की आपको एक फॉर्म देगा की सोच
लो इसको मैं डिलीट करूं या नहीं करो आईफोन
8 दे दिया रिकॉर्ड्स भी मतलब लाइन में
आपको जो लास्ट जो पास दिया गया है वहां तक
लाइन में डिलीट करता चला जाएगा स्टार्टिंग
से लास्ट तक ठीक है दी ओनली डायरेक्टली को
डिलीट कर रहा है ओनली मत राय को क्या
करेगा ये रिमूव करेगा जैसे भी कर सकते हो
तो ये रिमूव कमांड है उसे करना था तो ऐसे
ही कर सकते हो अब मैं आपको एक कमांड और
दिखता हूं जो हम उसे करने सीखना हूं वो है
अगर आपको कॉपी करना हो किसी एक डायरेक्टर
से दूसरी डायरेक्ट वो कैसे कर सकते हो ठीक
है अगर मैं एलएस करता हूं ठीक है ये मेरी
क्या है
मुझे इसको टाइम डायरेक्टर के अंदर कॉपी
करना है तो मैं उसे करूंगा उसके लिए कमांड
होती है सी पी को पी उसके बाद क्या है
आपके उसका एब्सलूट पाठ दीजिए ठीक है हमेशा
ट्राई करो एब्सलूट पाठ दो ठीक है अभी मैं
पार्ट नहीं दे रहा हूं पहले नोट
फाइल फ्री डॉट टेक्स्ट
उसके बाद डेस्टिनेशन मतलब कहां पर कॉपी
करना है तो कहां पर करूंगा मैं टीएमटी के
अंदर क्योंकि ये मेरा उसके ऊपर रोड
पार्टीशन के ऊपर टीम के अंदर मैं इसको
क्या करना चाहता हूं कॉपी करना चाहता हूं
सिंपली और मैंने कर दिया हिट इंटर अब ये
क्या है आपकी कॉपी हो गई अगर मैं एलएस
करके दिखता हूं आपको लेस टीएमटी करके
दिखाऊं आपको कोई टेंडर आपको यहां पे देखने
को देखेगी ये फाइल थ्री डॉट टी एक्स टी
यहां पर आपको देखने को मिलेगी ठीक है अगर
आपको मूव करना है या किसी फाइल को रिमूव
करना है तो वो आप कैसे करोगे ठीक है उसके
लिए कमांड होती है ठीक है मुझे क्या करना
है की पहले मेरे को
जो मेरी
फाइल्स में इसको मैंने रिमूव करना है इसका
नाम देना है मुझे न्यू फाइल
3.3xt सिंपली रिनेम करने के लिए मुझे यही
पर भी नाम करना है ठीक है तो मैं कैसे
क्या कर सकता हूं यही पर मैंने क्या कर
दिया इसका नाम लिखा न्यू फाइल डॉट कर दिया
अब ये क्या कर दिया मूव कर दिया इसमें
उसने नाम से ही टेंडर करता हूं
पहले आपको देखने को मिलेगी अगर मुझे एक
डायरेक्टर से दूसरे डायरेक्टरी में अगर
इसको मूव करना था सिंपली वही है बी कम आउट
कमांड ठीक है अब मैं क्या कर रहा हूं न्यू
file.t ठीक है और इसको मुझे क्या करना है
एमपी के अंदर करना है और अब इसका नया नाम
रखना चाहता हूं
यहां पर है ये फाइल अगर मैं राहत हूं अगर
यह रहा आपका टीएमटी के अंदर ये देखो यहां
पर
से होगी मुंह कमांड दोनों पर से आप उसे कर
सकते हो ठीक है अगर आपको लगता है की
एक कॉपी कमांड का एक इंपॉर्टेंट फीचर्स ये
है की कई बार आपके सामने एक ऐसी कंडीशन ए
गई की आपको एक डायरेक्टर से दूसरी
डायरेक्टर में किसी फाइल को के क्या करना
है कॉपी करना लेकिन क्या है की आपको वो
फूल पाठ के साथ जैसे की टीएमटी के अंदर
फाइल थ्री डॉट हा दी आपको टीएमटी के साथ
प्लस में फाइल होती है स्ट के साथ मतलब
पूरा ही रिकसिवली अगर आपको करना है तो आप
कैसे करते हो क कमांड के साथ आप क्या
करोगे वो एब्सलूट पाठ दीजिए हिफिन आर
देखिए उसके बाद वो एब्सलूट पाठ ठीक है
उसके बाद सोर्स का फूड डेस्टिनेशन तो आप
लिखकर सिमली उसको क्या का रहा है कॉपी कर
पाओगे तो आई होप यहां पर सबको मेरे ख्याल
से समझ में ए गया होगा एक और चीज होती है
की हम
की अगर यह जो फाइल्स है
मुझे कैसे पता चला है बाइनरी फाइल है या
कौन सी फाइल है उसके लिए कमांड होती है
फाइल कमांड ठीक है मुझे इसका देखना है की
किस टाइप की फाइल है फाइल लिखा मैंने और
उसका सिंपली नाम दीजिए मुझे अपडेटेड फाइल
अपडेटेड फाइल
पायल
रोटी है
ठीक है
जैसे मैंने क्या किया
और मैंने क्या कर दिया
जानेंगे ये तो जेपीजी फाइल है आपको देखने
को मिल रहा होगा तो इसको क्या करूंगा मैं
सिंपली इसको आईडेंटिफाई करने के लिए आपको
बहुत कम आई है जब आप
सिक्योरिटी में कम करते हो तो ठीक है
इसे भी आपको पता चलेगा एम्टी है ठीक है तो
फाइल क्या है आपका बेसिकली टाइप ऑफ फाइल
बता देता है
अब बात करते हैं ठीक है तो मैंने आज जो
आपको बताया की कैसे किसी पर डायरेक्टर और
क्रिएट करते हैं किसी भी फाइल को ग्रेट
करते हैं या किसी भी
कॉपी मूव कैसे करते हैं शायद आप लोगों को
समझ में ए गया होगा तो मुझे लगता है की आज
का सेशन इतना ही रखना चाहिए ठीक है बाकी
नेक्स्ट कल से करते हैं कल से इसी में
कंटिन्यू करेंगे मतलब की नेक्स्ट जो हमारा
प्लेन रहेगा अभी नेक्स्ट सेशंस हैं अभी वन
और हाफ है तो नेक्स्ट टाइम से थोड़ा सा और
ज्यादा जाएगा आई होप की कितने लोग हमारे
साथ 21 बहुत ही ज्यादा ए गई यार
कैसे हैं आई डोंट नो की क्या करना है
ओके
हमारे भी हमें भी मोटिवेट मिले आप लोगों
के साथ
ठीक है